normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government Tommy
Robinson charged after arrest at
anti-Semitism March The 40-Year-Old and
I love how they do this whose real name
is Step yaxley Lennon was arrested in
lond London on Sunday I don't know why
it's relevant but they do that a lot and
I think they do it because they're
attacking him and they're attacking his
family in one of the videos from the
protest the cops demand his address and
he gets pissed and he's like with all of
these cameras and all these people
standing around me think I'm going to
give you my address put my family in
danger here's the news activist Tommy
Robinson has been charged after
attending Sunday's March against
anti-Semitism in London The 40-Year-Old
former leader of the far right English
Defense League they say was arrested at
the event for failing to comply with a
direction to disperse let's just be
clear he was in a cafe he had ordered
breakfast he was waiting for his food
and the last thing he says before they
ARR him I think it was like the last
thing he's like then pay me back for my
breakfast and they were like no and I'm
like I don't think it's unreasonable to
be like okay just pay me back for my
breakfast the assumption is he's going
to leave if you do and the cops like nah
like you lose your money and get out I
mean what if he was just like can I take
my breakfast to go I bet they still
would have said no organizers had warned
warned him he would not be welcome at
the March held in central London after
he signals attention to his intention to
attend in an update on Monday the
Metropolitan Police said Steven Lennon
of Bedford Shire has been charged with
failing to comply with a section 35
Direction excluding a person from an
area
he has been bailed to to appear at
Westminster magistrates court on 22nd
January the Met said he told officers he
was at the march in his capacity as a
journalist 60,000 people took part in
the event this is the state of the UK
right now that if you are an activist or
a media personality they will just
straight kick you out they will arrest
you for your speech they will lie they
will make up reasons to shut you down
there are so many stories about what a
Speaker's Corner the famous place where
people would stand in speak now now they
all get arrested M only acceptable
government opinions and the worst thing
is look at how the police behave I got
to be honest I I watch this and I'm like
I totally understand the founding
fathers mhm I will never forget the uh
video of the police going in and and
raiding the house and and pulling out
the autistic girl did you guys see that
the teenage girl that like called like
somebody a lesbian did not even do that
she didn't even do that she basically
said I think she's like Grand her
grandmother is a lesbian and and like
this girl I mean she had I think she
said they said she had scoliosis and
they're dragging her out this teenage
girl and cops are in there like can you
imagine what it must be like to be the
cop that was called a lesbian and just
like sit there like that's evil to look
at this girl that you're saying she's
autistic and you're just sitting there
like yeah I got
you imping something bad she's like oh
she's like gr like it does that have to
be negative does that I mean there's a
million different words she could have
used that would have been far more in
if off that's the point the police said
by saying it it was a hate offense but
again does that imply she hates her
grandmother and then it was a hate
offense she really her grandmother the
government is allowed to say whether
you'll be arrested and for whatever
reason yeah and that's it and that
happened a time it's funny because we're
talking just a moment ago about Ireland
wanting to pass this law where if you
possess things that may in sight that
means they're going to walk up to you
and say give me your phone and they're
going to they're going to open Twitter
and they're see a picture on Twitter
like oh this is on your phone and
they're going to say something like when
I inspected the defendant's phone I saw
images of racist content that I believe
were on his device and then you can
argue in court I was he pulled up
Twitter and he was looking through posts
and someone retweeted something I had no
control over it they're going to be like
so you admit it you had it on your phone
they are just going to decide in in was
it was the UK where they arrested this
woman yeah it was the it was met police
yeah just like Kafka it's I mean it's
just like the trial well they they tried
to do that one Copco reference tonight
it's just I will give you more if you
want yeah that's my favorite part of me
being on the show The the thing about in
in the trial so this guy K he gets home
and there's a you know police rumaging
around in his room and uh taking his
stuff and searching his stuff and mostly
what ends up happening is he's really
really ashamed he gets arrested people
are looking at him nobody will tell him
what he did wrong you know he can never
get a reasonable answer of what he did
wrong and finally he just gets to run
around by the courts and everything and
eventually they just kill him in the
street and he's
grateful well the the uh the Harrison
Floyd the Trump case in fton County when
they tried to revoke his bond they did
the same thing they were reading tweets
that Harrison Floyd put up and they
would go Fanny Willis would go and
actually read the responses and be like
see look what this incited and it's like
just some Rando with like three
followers that said like oh probably her
that's what I'm saying like at that
point if that's going to be admissible
to to try and revoke somebody's Bond and
put them in a prison where 12 people or
whatever it is have died there in the
last you know year and a half four
people one guy died of bed bug bites if
you're going to revoke somebody's Bond
because of what other people are saying
on Twitter in response to what you say
so now not only do you have to censor
yourself but you have to think about how
others are going to react to what you
say that's crazy well that's the that's
the soldier nsen right that's the gulag
archipelago is you get arrested they
don't tell you what you did wrong they
don't tell you why you're there they get
you to say stuff maybe mentioning past
colleagues then past colleagues get
Dragged In arrested not told what they
did wrong and it's really just because
you're Associated that happened all
through you know that whole period and
behind the Iron Curtain it's insane I
think it happens here too we just talk
and now it's happening here and well
because we don't I think part of what's
going on is we just don't believe that
this can happen in America it's shocking
to believe that this can happen in
America it's shocking to believe that
you know our rights can just be trampled
like this we don't believe that it's
possible and I think that that is a
little bit of a naive and I think that
is an overconfidence in our position um
and it's getting in our way of seeing
what's being done to to our country I
think we're winning though right I can't
speak for the UK or for Ireland but I do
see you know in Holland gear Wilder's
party wins and they're they're saying
you know big things coming Javier Malay
wins in Argentina and he has vowed to uh
he said it is non-negotiable they're
shutting down the central bank that is
crazy you know what's funny is whenever
I mention that to people I'm like oh did
you see that the uh new Argentinian
president put out a statement saying the
closure of the central bank is
non-negotiable everybody
says in a manner of speaking they fear
for his well-being yeah well they
probably should James Lindsay was
posting about that he was like and soon
there will be major crises in Argentina
that were just unforeseen yeah how could
this happen but anyway my point is I
think we're winning right especially
when it as it pertains to speech uh
Danny pochu made the point last week I
think it was last week where he's like
as soon as Elon bought Twitter everybody
went men aren't women it's like
everybody was finally allowed to say it
and everyone just went off like that was
awesome but isn't it absolutely insane
to look back and be like did you know
that on one of the major social media
platforms you were not allowed to say
men aren't women you would be banned
like Megan Murphy was so that being said
we had some pretty dark and creepy days
but we're we're we're clawing back I
think we we've been winning that doesn't
mean we have the majority it doesn't
mean we are going to win it means we
have been consistently gaining ground
you've got uh the daily wide part of the
trailer for that new movie they're doing
lady Ballers it looks hilarious I can't
wait to see it it's out on Friday and uh
it's it's it's a comedy movie about men
who decide to identify as women to play
on a b play on a bunch of sporting teams
and win a bunch of money and it's it's
funny so uh uh I just think with things
like this the culture is being clawed
back I'll also do a shout out we did the
culture War podcast pre-recorded went up
last Friday with Richie Jackson a
professional skateboarder and I'm
getting messages from tons of pro
skateboarders who are like we agree
right the the the woke people who are
coming into these sporting events who
are coming into video games they don't
know about the culture they don't care
about the culture they actually actively
despise the culture of various they want
to destroy it and now they're losing
more people are speaking up more people
are saying dude I just don't care I want
to just read my comic books I just want
to play video games I just want to esape
I think it's funny that during gamergate
the meme was we just wanted to play
video games and now what I hear from
skateboarders as wokeness is causing
problems in skateboarding it's dude we
just want to skate so when more and more
people start speaking up I just see I
think we're winning you look at Joe
Biden's failure you look how bad he's
doing I think we're winning so I'm
having a good time you know it's it's
it's a long road ahead of us 2024 is
going to be wild AF but it is what it is
yeah I think people are frustrated
because it doesn't this idea of like oh
we'll let you live how you want to live
and everything will be okay has
obviously not turned out to be the other
side's thought they want to be the
dominant culture in every sphere they
enter and if you have something you love
like skateboarding or whatever Niche
culture you're into to know that
ultimately you're going to have to
dismantle it to accommodate this major
Theology of you know wokeness and
whatever else it's sort of you either
need to decide to protect it or you're
going to lose it and I think we're
seeing this replicated in culture in
geopolitics everywhere right now it's
sort of a make or break moment if you
will it is could we be at an inflection
point possibly potentially isn't that
what we keep hearing from Joe Biden that
we're in an inflection point I can't
believe you canoun hopefully it inflects
hopefully it inflections him right out
of it yeah nothing matter for him he he
can't run he can't he can't be The N he
can barely walk I mean come
on mortal enemy the most likely scenario
is at the the convention when when is
when is the convention is going to be in
May right I think it's in May we're
talking five months six months well the
audition the audition is on Thursday the
audition is on Thursday it's to santis
new when and I hate saying this because
I'm a where are they doing it I don't
know where but Hannity's hosting it
moderating it maybe uh I I mean Dan
santis is an awful awful debat he just
he has no personality uh I mean he's
getting smeared with this with the uh
the high heels and you know whatever
he's doing I mean look he did a pretty
good job in Florida overall I mean we
did have lockdowns during covid it
wasn't you know what everybody said my
wife was out of work for like seven or
eight months where she wasn't allowed to
work kind of let the counties deal with
it on their own but as much as I this
pains me to say Gavin Nome is a I mean
he's like a charismatic dude that is
going to Suave his way through this
debate and Dan santis is just going to
be stumbling all over himself I I I
think this is the audition and Nome
comes out looking like a I mean just a
polished herd to be honest with you but
yeah but but it means the only thing
they can do is decree him the nominee
there there will not be a primary he's
not going to be on the ballot people
aren't going to vote for him the
convention is going to happen they're
going to say all in favor of just having
Gavin new be the Nomine I and then
everyone's going to be like I didn't
vote for this guy M but but what I'm
saying he's terrible and he's done
terrible things to California Absol
absolutely but what I'm saying is this
debate with the santis is going to be
that kind of put his like look
everybody's talking about it I mean V
said in in the last debate just tell us
who your cand going to be it's to
formally introduce the idea that he is
he is the a parent it's going to put him
on that thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net next
time